[Musique]
salut à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
de tva 78 nous sommes le lundi 17 juin
voici le sommaire
objectif récolter 90 mille euros pour
des associations caritatives le tournoi
de rugby cette de coeur se déroulait ce
week-end au stade de porchefontaine à
versailles un événement sportif et
solidaire qui revenait cette année pour
la 8e édition
c'était la huitième également pour la go
sport running plus de 16 mille coureurs
ont pris le départ dans le parc du
château de versailles dimanche une
course royal de 15 km ou des parcours
plus court il y en avait pour tous les
goûts
et puis ceux qui passent le bac
aujourd'hui en seront peut-être les
premiers élèves le ms porte business
qu'on ouvre à la rentrée prochaine à
guyancourt l école de commerce forme aux
métiers du sport on en parle avec
mohammad atiq directeur de
l'établissement
et puis sur ce plateau des découvertes
également à notamment à l'équipe h boy
championne d'île de france élite en
catégorie u15 ses joueurs et son
entraîneur seront nos invités
cette information d'abord que l'on a
appris la semaine dernière la ryder cup
2018 a boosté l'économie française
d'après une étude commandée par le
comité d'organisation l'événement gaulle
qui sait a déroulé fin septembre 2018 à
saint quentin en yvelines a généré 235
millions d'euros
c'est quasiment 20 millions d'euros de
plus par rapport à la dernière édition
sur le sol européen c'était en 2014 à
gleneagles en écosse
plus de 270 mille personnes avaient
assisté à la compétition au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
allié à sport et à solidarité l'esprit
du tournoi à 7 de coeur qui revenait à
ce week-end à versailles pour une
huitième édition une trentaine d'équipés
étaient présentes au stade de
porchefontaine pour ce traditionnel
tournoi de rugby à 7 et surtout pour
récolter des fonds pour des associations
caritatives solidarité et entraide deux
des valeurs du rugby mise en lumière
chaque année par cette de coeur au
programme de nombreuses animations dont
un tournoi relevé qui se joue à sept
contre sept
mais l'événement se distingue avec son
angle caritatif
depuis son lancement le tournoi à 7 de
coeur a permis de récolter trois cent
vingt mille euros pour des associations
le fait par le biais de levée de fonds
mais également par des opérations de
communication
en essayant d'avoir le plus beau
résultat pour pouvoir parler le mieux
possible des associations qui sont
bénéficiaires du tournoi pour sa
huitième édition cette de coeur a
soutenu cinq associations caritatives
dont celle de l'ancien international
français et entraîneur de biarritz
patrice lagisquet chrysalide accompagne
les parents d'enfants déficients mentaux
et laval tâches qu'on a avec des
tournois comme celui ci qui nous
permettent de
recueillir des fonds c'est que ça me
donne une autonomie pour lancer des
projets on a été pionnier sur la
création les auxiliaires de vie scolaire
sur les premières classes d'intégration
dans les années au tout début des années
et chaque fois c'est grâce à des
soutiens comme celui d'aujourd'hui que
qu'on a pu lancer ses projets sur le
terrain des joueurs venus de toute la
france mais aussi d'angleterre et de
chine
et parmi la trentaine d'équipés
représenter quelques habitués nous ça
fait ça fait pas mal d'années compte on
est là on est à versailles et à chaque
fois c'est toujours un plaisir de jouer
ici le voir le niveau un peu et de
surtout de participer à une asso
caritatives pour ces gens là et pour le
rugby en plus pour leur cas c'est un
tournoi très relevé sportivement et en
même temps le caritatif c'est la cerise
sur le gâteau c'est le fait de pouvoir
jouer au rugby et faire même temps une
belle action bonne action transformer
l'objectif de 90000 euros affiché cette
année sera probablement atteint avec une
météo rendez-vous vous l'avez vu sur ce
dernier sujet le week-end était
également fait pour les amateurs de
course à pied dans le parc du château de
versailles dimanche le groupe go sport
organisée à la huitième édition de son
événement running quatre parcours
étaient au programme pour satisfaire les
athlètes mais aussi les sportifs du
dimanche les images de nicolas d'ombré
ils étaient plus de 16 mille coureurs à
s'élancer dans la 8ème go sport running
premier départ dès 9 heures du matin
pour les plus aguerris un 15 km dans des
conditions presque idéales et un cadre
royal le parc du château de versailles
pour la danse royale
on a accès inde est une des parties du
jardin qui était jusque là inaccessibles
c'est les jardins de la ferme de marie
antoinette
donc je pense que les coureurs vont
vraiment prendre beaucoup de plaisir le
cadre autour du château c'est quand même
assez assez sympa ça change des autres
courses où c'est beaucoup plus urbain
là on a un côté fort et un côté au
parquet un côté château les paysages
sont sublimes
par contre c'était dur j'ai imaginé que
ce serait du plat mais non c'est des
faux plats ça monte ça descend
conservant la course aussi un peu plus
ludique du coup un peu dur pour moi
aujourd'hui
il a été mondialement je lui ai servi
des bons débuts à premier parti quand
c'est vrai même lâché mais finalement
c'est moi qui les a lâchés au total
quatre courses étaient proposés
objectifs de l'événement qui se veut
familial le rendre accessible à tous les
niveaux c'est le sport accessible à tous
à tous les niveaux à tous les âges
et c'est une course conviviale aussi au
delà de ça les gens se déguise voilà les
gens ont le sourire
il n'y a pas forcément de recherche de
performance on est là pour se faire
plaisir et et c'est ma vision du sport
aujourd'hui et l'ambiance était bon
enfant au départ de la course des
princesses 8 km de parcours que les
participants pouvaient accomplir déguisé
non on est pas déguiser en nature s'est
naturellement montré à ma femme que je
peux courant aussi en robe rouge et j'ai
évité les talons
ça sera pour lundi prochain et aller une
page football à présent avec la coupe du
monde féminine qui se tient en ce moment
en france après les bleus le stade
municipal est de croissy sur seine avec
une deuxième sélection engagées dans le
mondial les causses et les joueuses
britanniques se sont entraînés hier
devant le public
après deux défaites dans le groupe d les
écossaises sont déjà éliminés du mondial
elle prépare cependant leur dernier
match de poule face à l'argentine ce
mercredi au parc des princes à paris
football toujours mais chez les
masculins ont joué ce week end à
verneuil-sur-seine la finale de la coupe
des yvelines a senior et ses lacets
vélizy qui a été sacré score sans appel
7 but à 0 contre carrière grésillons
allahyar chine n'aura donc pas été
respectée puisque sont les béliziens qui
faisait office de petit poucet dans
cette finale évoluant une division plus
bas en championnat par rapport à leurs
adversaires troisième coupe des yvelines
de l'histoire pour laisser vélizy c'est
un petit coup de tonnerre pour le
football yvelinois laurent fournier a
été nommé nouvel entraîneur de l'ess
fois ci une carrière de coach et surtout
de joueurs avec de nombreux trophées
remportés
autant dire que le club pisciacais
pensionnaire de nationale 2 nourrit de
sérieux espoirs pour la saison prochaine
nickel et demi d'euros et wilfrid richy
formé à l'olympique lyonnais où il
disputera deux cent soixante matchs dans
les années 80 passé par saint-etienne
marseille et paris laurent fournier 54
ans est aujourd'hui le nouvel entraîneur
de l'as poissy conférence de presse ce
jeudi matin pour le nouvel homme fort du
football pisciacais c'est toujours
valorisant d'être sur un terrain de
de faire partager ce que c'est ce qui
nous a permis de gagner pas mal de
titres
de faire comprendre aux jeunes que
de travailler à l'extérieur c'est
toujours mieux que de travailler à
l'intérieur et que le sport et ben c'est
le foot c'est populaire c'est ça permet
d'aller de s'extérioriser d'être bien
dans sa peau son ambition la montée
d'ici deux ans laisse poissy
actuellement national de la 4e division
française et qui vient de terminer cette
saison à la 9e place
je pense que on a effectivement d'un
côté la difficulté d'être du monde
amateur mais c'est un monde formidable
et d'un autre côté des anciens pros qui
sont fédéraux donc c'est de retrouver
l'alchimie entre ces jeunes donc ces
jeunes issus de la fois ci de les faire
monter en nationale 2 et ses anciens de
les entourer
je pense que c'est très important
aujourd'hui pour réussir notre projet
le psg est le red star créteil lors
fourni retrouve donc une place sur le
banc d'une équipe francilienne plus de
trois ans après avoir quitté son dernier
poste d'entraîneur il reprend du service
et ne devrait pas déroger à sa
réputation d' homme combatif et
possédant un certain franc-parler
j'ai pas trouvé que c'était incohérent
cette année j'ai juste trouvé qu'il y
avait les résultats étaient en dents de
scie donc peut-être problème
de mental mais on l'a vu le mental n'y a
pas que la s fois ci il ya certaines
équipes comme le paris saint germain qui
ont perdu contre manchester alors qu'ils
avaient mené 2 0 et là aussi c'est pas
un problème de qualité
c'est juste un problème de d'exigence et
quand on est exigeant je crois qu'on
arrive à faire pas mal de choses
une petite pensée pour ceux acquis à
passent le bac avec notamment ce lundi
la tant redoutée épreuve de philosophie
alors certains de ses futurs bacheliers
seront peut-être sur les bancs de cette
école à la rentrée
le ms pass'portes business school et
pour en parler son président est en
plateau c'est moi mais natig bonsoir
bonsoir président fondateur donc de
cette école qui va ouvrir en octobre
boulevard vauban à guyancourt quelques à
quelques mètres des locaux télé 78 le
msc c'est une école de commerce des
métiers du sport pour la présenter
exactement le même sport business school
est une école 100% une école de commerce
100% sport business
la forme les futurs leaders dans les
métiers du management du marketing de
l'événementiel sportif et hospitalité
sponsoring etc
toujours dans les métiers du sport pour
revenir sur votre parcours vous êtes
originaire de trappes et vous avez été
sportif de haut niveau en athlétisme
origine j'ai dit originaire de trappes
pourquoi créer cette école pourquoi vous
avez eu l'idée de créer cette école dans
fait c'est venu d'une simple idée en
lors de la réforme macron du suivi
de celle de françois hollande il y avait
cette réforme de la formation
professionnelle et puis on s'est posé la
question moi même issu du monde du sport
de l'univers du sport on s'est posé la
question qu'est ce qui a été fait autour
de l'éducation de ce qu'on pouvait
proposer en termes de métiers autour
d'eux des sports et du coup ben on a
travaillé sur ce projet d'étude de
marché en études de marché
on s'est aperçu qu'en france il existait
très peu d'écoles spécialisées dans les
métiers du sport business
rien à voir avec ce tableau en forme des
éducateurs ou une autre là on est
vraiment en école de commerce peut
essayer dans lé monde dans l'univers du
sport business et le créneau du sport
business on imagine c'est un univers en
plein développement avec une économie
aussi du sport toujours plus complexes
exactement on sait que la bulle sport a
complètement explosé et à prendre une
place considérable dans dans notre vie
de tous les jours
et justement les les industriels et les
entreprises sans demande justement de ce
type de des jeunes diplômés prêtes à
l'emploi
ce que le les écoles généralistes ne
sont pas capables aujourd'hui de fournir
dont vous avez parlé des différents
métiers que l'on peut que l'on peut
exercer après être passé par le ms les
différents cursus proposés au sein de
msc des cursus qui sont proposés dès
après le bac
tout à fait c'est du post bac jusque
jusqu'au m2 donc un jeune bachelier peut
intégrer un bachelor un donc un bac + 1
suivent sont son cursus jusqu'en b3
intégrer une entreprise lors de sa
préparation du de cursus en tant que
alternant ou stagiaires si c'est si
c'est dans le cadre d'un bachelor
ensuite donc à à l'issue du du bac + 3
on peut devenir chargé de communication
de marketing avoir une équipe en charge
ensuite si on continue on prend le cycle
grandes écoles jusqu'au master 2 bac +5
ou
on devient directeur marketing
management etc autour des métiers du
sport business et les intervenants qui
sont il est ce que son ce sont des
spécialistes peut-être des économistes
du sport des spécialistes du secteur
tout à fait justement l'intérêt de ce
type de formation ces deux d'agrémenter
autour d'un programme de blocs de
compétences généralistes des des modules
des blocs de compétences dans le sport
ça peut être du droit du sport ça peut
être dans l'économie du sport ça peut
être dans dans différents voilà dans
différents domaines qui a trait au sport
la première rentrée ça sera le 1er
octobre prochain combien d'étudiants
allez vous accueillir pour cette
première promotion et jusqu'à 300
étudiants donc
là les places sont très limitées il faut
il faut vraiment se dépêcher pour
pouvoir voir sa petite place ce qu'il en
reste encore il en reste encore très peu
très peu pour présenter votre école
alors il ya de nombreuses portes
ouvertes les prochaines je crois que
c'est ce samedi il y en a toutes les
semaines on retrouve le programme
d'ailleurs sur le site internet de votre
école il y en a toutes les semaines fait
il y en a toutes les semaines
en fait on a mis en place un programme
qui permet de donner le maximum de
visibilité aux jeunes diplômés donc post
bac même mais aussi ceux qui sortent de
licence alors donner cette possibilité
de venir visiter les locaux qui sont
complètement atypique puisque l'idée
c'était pas seulement d'apporter des
locaux avec quatre murs mais aussi
apporter une image une identité une adn
à cette école l'étudiant qui viendra
dans cette école il
il aura forcément envie de dit
travailler deux des six investir et puis
devenir l'ambassadeur de l'école et
comment ils l'intègrent est-ce que c'est
sûr sélection contre atelier c'est là
aussi on est
signe écoles comme les autres on est
reconnu par des titre rncp donc des
diplômes bac + 3 et bac + 5
il ya des épreuves à à l'issue de chaque
chaque admission
et puis ben c'est en fonction des
niveaux de chacun et le coût d'une année
ems donc pour les b1 b2 on est dans
l'ordre de 8000 euros
on est dans la fourchette basse d'une
école
classique et après bombe à ses 8000 5
mai du b3 au m2 on a les opc au qui
prennent en charge l'intégralité du
financement de la formation et j'appelle
toutes les informations sur le site
internet de le ms sport business school
merci à mohamed ali
je rappelle que vous êtes le président
et fondateur de cet établissement qui va
ouvrir à la rentrée prochaine à
guyancourt l'actualité sportive qui vous
a peut-être échappé ces dernières
semaines c'est la coupe du monde de bmx
et le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillait
les 7 8 et 9 juin deux manches de la
coupe du monde à 2 160 concurrents issus
de 25 nationalités se sont affrontés
l'événement affichait complet mélanie
poquet et or il est onze des tribunes
pleines à craquer près de 12000
personnes sont venues encourager les
meilleurs pilotes de bmx au stade
vélodrome de 50 ans
c'est agréable d'entendre cette
effervescence
c'est très bon ce qui plaît c'est de
voir tous ces pilotes qui sont vraiment
très fort et qui roule vraiment à un
niveau très supérieur près de deux cent
soixante concurrents dont 100 français
se sont affrontés pour les cinquième et
sixième manche de la coupe du monde de
la discipline
c'est chez nous c'est là puisqu'on
connaît le mieux donc toute la saison se
prépare dessus et c'est vraiment
l'événement le plus important pour nous
de cette saison
de plus en plus de pratiquants de bmx
ans dans notre pays et puis ensuite sous
l'angle de l'accompagnement vers le haut
niveau
le pôle olympique ici à saint quentin il
contribue beaucoup mais on a cette
capacité à s'installer de manière assez
permanente sur les podiums au niveau
international pari réussi pour les
français manon valentino a terminé
dimanche sur la plus haute marche du
podium
les français étaient là à crier encore
et encore et je me suis dit il faut que
j'aille tant que geste et j'ai poussé
dans les bosses s'est passé c'est juste
incroyable d'avoir gagné ici
chez les hommes le français joris daudet
termine 3e samedi-- deuxième dimanche
les prochaines manches de la coupe du
monde se dérouleront les 14 et 15
septembre aux états unis et parmi les
athlètes tricolores en lice vous l'avez
entendu dans ce sujet et joris daudet et
qui a signé à deux podiums lors de ces
deux manches de coupe du monde de bmx
mk les limites euros a profité de
l'événement pour lui poser trois
questions
[Musique]
je me suis lancé dans le bmx parce que
j'adore les sensations fortes
j'adore la vitesse et j'adore les sauts
et demi ça tout ça tout ça en commun
donc voilà
[Musique]
super carrière beaucoup de beaucoup de
titres beaucoup de choses que j'avais
pas espérer dans tu donc super kf super
content d'eux pour l'instant mais c'est
pas fini
l'avenir pour l'instant le bmx pour
l'instant jusqu'à temps que je puisse en
faire et ensuite on verra
j'ai pas l'âge du baseball pour leur
première en coupe d'europe les cougars
de montigny le bretonneux assure
l'équipe à saint-quentinoise espérer une
demi finale elle a fait mieux troisième
place obtenue dans la set club qui se
disputaient est du 5 au 9 juin à brno en
république tchèque après une
qualification in extremis en demi finale
les hommes de rodolphe le meur se sont
ensuite inclinés contre les allemands de
ndoffane vic futur vainqueur de ce
tournoi dans la petite finale eysines et
montrent un ont disposé à des
biélorusses de minsk sur le score de 3 2
deux corvées européenne donc les cougars
jouer ce week-end la dernière journée de
la saison régulière de d1 et victoire
5-1 dans la première rencontre contre le
puc paris avant de s'incliner à 2 à 1
dans le match 2 ils terminent donc
deuxièmes du groupe b de d1 le week-end
prochain les yvelinois seront engagés
dont la première journée des playoffs et
c'est un gros morceau dès le début avec
car le club affronte roues en revanche
de la finale de d1 de la saison passée
perdu par les cougars de montigny le
bretonneux eux sont sur le toit de
l'ile-de-france les âges boys son
champion régional élite en catégorie u15
c'est du handball et victoire contre
l'entente massy ouest et soldes de juin
dernier c'était à saint-michel-sur-orge
également en essonne et pour en parler
quatre invités mohamed mokrani
l'entraîneur aimé aussi lubin capitaine
nathan et baptiste qui sont joueurs de
l'équipe bonsoir à vous quatre
merci à d'être avec moi en plateau je
vais vous donner d'abord la parole à
vous mohamed mokrani quelle réaction
suite à cette victoire c'est finalement
la victoire du collectif tout à fait
c'est ce qu'a fait la différence entre
les autres équipes et nous concrètement
sur chaque équipe il y avait des très
grosses individualités
la différence s'est faite sur le
collectif ou
où les garçons ont fait en sorte de
faire qu'un et c'est ce qui a fait que
la victoire bon l'humain de votre rôle
de capitaine qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence sur ce match
sur la saison aussi pour votre équipe dh
boy là
confiance en soi la confiance qu'on a
entre nous la motivation surtout parce
que y'en a qui font beaucoup de trajets
pour ce sport car motivée et aussi comme
l'a dit l'entraîneur
la cohésion et on précisera que ça fait
qu'elle n'a qu'un an d'existence cette
équipe on va avoir l'occasion d'en
parler dans un instant nathan c'était un
match compliqué face à hama si oui les
scores étaient très serrés 1 un coup il
nous dépasser à on prend et après on les
rattraper mais à la fin on a fait la
différence en les dépassant
donc moi si c'est aussi un autre grand
bassin du handball ya cette équipe de
massy qui évolue en deuxième division 2
de handball la pro league et c'est ça
donc il ya on imagine un vivier de
jeunes très important aussi et baptiste
hosni ce tour de table avec vous ça vous
fait quoi d'être champion d'île de
france dès la première saison pour les
all boys c'est un grand sentiment est un
grand honneur d'être sacré champion
après un an de travail acharné et même
s'il ya eu des blessures entre temps le
groupe à a tout fait pour
pour arriver à la falla au bon
aboutissement et vous avez ramener la
coupe à la maison vous l'avez aussi
amener sur ce plateau à leur âge boy je
précise que ça veut dire
handball ouest yvelines c'est une équipe
intercommunal du bassin mantois qui a
été créée en avril 2018 ce sont des
jeunes de 14 à 15 ans issus de huit
clubs du territoire
et si une équipe qui évolue donc au plus
haut niveau régional dans la catégorie
l'élite -15 mohamed mokrani pourquoi
créer pourquoi créer cette équipe quel
était le but
à la base le but alors ce qui se passait
que l'année dernière donc je suis
l'entraîneur de j'étais entraîneur de
l'as mantaise donc baptiste et et lubin
faisait partie de cette équipe et on a
fini 9e de l'élite l'année dernière en
ayant des enfants des jeunes que deux
premières années il s'avère qu'on s'est
déplacé à 7 ou 8
ce qui était trop peu pour le niveau de
jeu qui était qui et 2
dadaux au niveau des enfants de 13 14
ans et le constat était que très
rapidement j'ai fait un diagnostic et
sur les clubs aux alentours y avait des
individus qui étaient là qui sont
trouvés seuls dans leur club
l'idée c'était de rassembler les jeunes
qui ont un certain niveau pour qu'ils
puissent avoir la même pratique le même
encadrement et surtout créé à créer une
grosse équipe de notre bassin mais vous
attendiez à pareil résultat dès la
première saison obtenir ce titre de
champion d'ile-de-france est ce que ça
faisait partie des objectifs de la
saison alors je n'aurais pas dit mais
oui l'année dernière s'il s'avère qu'on
était c'était une très grande surprise
de faire partie de l'élite dès la
première année on a perdu des matches
contre des joueurs qui faisait quinze
centimètres d'un centimètre de plus que
et j'étais persuadé que l'année d'après
avec du travail et comme a dit lubin des
jeunes qui sont motivés assidus
concentré ça aurait fait la différence
et ça m'a fait et comment on crée une
cohésion aussi vite des jeunes qui
viennent de huit clubs différents
comment on crée une équipe très vite une
cohésion au sein de cette équipe ont
créé des cohésions faisant des moments
conviviaux
on sort il passe des moments entre les
seins denses et les autres sans que je
puisse le savoir donc ils ont créé la
victoire elle est aussi la leur victoire
c'est ils ont fait en sorte de pouvoir
créer un vrai groupe et nous
l'aboutissement c'est au mois d'avril
on a été en est parti cinq jours sur un
séjour sportif en haute savoie avec
l'ensemble du groupe
je pense que ça fait partie prégnante de
la victoire qu'ils aient lieu le 2 juin
dernier
on va leur poser la question il parle
sous votre contrôle l'adaptation elle
s'est fait très vite lubin l'adaptation
entre les différents joueurs qui
venaient de ses huit clubs différents
oui assez vite enfin on a eu du mal au
début 40 ce qu'on ne sait pas du tout
on avait du mal à faire confiance mais
on a vite compris que l'on pouvait avoir
confiance en eux pour avoir confiance en
tout le monde et que tout le monde se
donne et se donner à fond pour faire le
travail le mieux possible et qu'on
arrive dans cette équipe on connaît
personne n'attend alors qu'on connaît
peut-être les camarades de son équipe
l'on connaît pas forcément les autres
coéquipiers comment comment ça se passe
les premières
on commence par les voir et leur parler
essayer de faire connaissance et après
sur le jeu et sur les moments extérieur
de l'entraînement bas on va les voir et
on essaie de se connaître pareille d'un
autre côté ça a été très rapide pour
vous j'ai oublié votre prénom c'est
baptiste par la bâtisse a été très
rapide aussi l'adaptation pour vais très
très rapide et très facile ou si on va
regarder déjà dès la saison prochaine
alors peut-être qu'ils ne seront plus
dans la catégorie des 14 15 ans l'idée
c'est de reproposer chaque année une
nouvelle catégorie de faire des
détections peut-être fait donc au vu de
la réussite de ceux de ce projet sur la
première année donc dès l'année
prochaine
il ya la quasi totalité du groupe qui
passe en moins de dix-huit donc on l'a
su avant-hier donc c'est la petite
douche qu'on a pris parce que jusqu'à
présent c'était des moins de 17 et
d'année prochaine ça sera des moins de
18 ans globe
ils ont 15 ans pour la grande majorité
ils joueront contre des jeunes qui rompt
qui se rendent eux leur 18e année donc
du coup on va créer une équipe moins de
17 et en parallèle donc on reste sur une
équipe moins de 15 avec les détections
qui ont été faites sur ces clubs avec
cinq clubs pour les prochaines dix huit
et l'équipe se crée tout doucement de
côté mais le bidon que c'est d'abord
diverses catégories plus qu'une comme
cette saison les âges boy du bassin en
toi champion d'île de france u 15 élite
u15 de handball bravo à vous et merci
d'être passé sur ce plateau
merci une découverte à présent dans ce
magazine c'est le kayak-polo un sport
qui se pratique donc sur l'eau dans un
kayak et le principe c'est de mettre un
maximum de buts une journée de
championnat régional est de la
discipline se tenait ce dimanche à lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
les images signées nicolas landry c'est
un sport qui mélange handball et
water-polo le tous pratiquants à bord
d'un kayak le kayak polo se joue à cinq
contre cinq sur l'eau un match se divise
en deux mi temps de dix minutes
le principe mettre plus de points que
l'équipe adverse dans un but situé en
hauteur c'est du kayak faut savoir faire
du bateau et après dès qu'on prend la
balle en main on oublie le bateau donc
ce n'est pas bon en kayak à la base on
n'arrive pas très bien à manoeuvrer et
ensuite après c'est un véritable sport
collectif
on est obligé de mettre en place des
tactiques des techniques pour pour pour
jouer comme dans tous les sports
collectifs de petits terrains pour
savoir où on est où son nouveau
coéquipier et savoir où on va surtout
pour aller vers le but et marqué les
gens qui sont plutôt attirés c'est les
familles les amis ont à dire les gens
qui passent parce que ils sont jamais vu
cette heure activités une journée du
championnat régional de ce sport se
déroulait à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines l'occasion de faire
connaître aux curieux cette discipline
encore méconnue
ça commence à se développer de plus en
plus surtout grâce aux jeux olympiques
les personnes se rapproche beaucoup de
des clubs de kayak
après découvre des activités comme le
kayak polo qui n'est pas diffusée à la
télévision
attrapons pratiquer le kayak polo depuis
15 ans le club compte aujourd'hui une
centaine de licenciés un sport
intéressant en vue de l'été avant de
vous laisser un rendez vous à ne pas
manquer le week end prochain la 21e
édition de la revancharde se tient et
dimanche 23 juin sur la colline
d'elancourt 200 participants sont
attendus pour cette finale de challenge
vtt et nous serons en pleine journée
olympique en plus un sur ce site qui
accueillera à des épreuves des jo de
2024 le rendez vous est fixé à partir de
9h c'est la fin de ce sept huit sports
passé une excellente semaine sportive
sur tv 78
[Musique]